[Applaus]
ich möchte heute über Kant sprechen
Immanuel Kant der Philosoph
vor über 700 Jahren am 22 April 1724 in Königsberg
geboren am 12 februar 1804 dort gestorben
das ist wenn man einigermaßen intelligente
ist da dann muss man wirklich sagen das war
wirklich unglaublich wie scharf der kann denken
und formulieren konnte es ist zweifellos sei
sei Hauptwelt die Kritik der Rahmen Vernunft das
gilt nicht ohne als einflussreichstes Werk in der
Geschichte der Philosophie es ist der kant war
definitiv da brauchen wir eine diskutieren das
war Aufklärer im besten Sinn er hat es geschafft
verwarne Erkenntnisse aufzulösen ich komme mal
so stehen lassen der der Kante hat durch seinen
eigenen Schritt im philosophieren gemacht wo man
wirklich sagen kann das hat weltgeschichtliche
Bedeutung gehabt hoffe ich kann Zweifel hier im
Auditorium aber und das sollten wir haben heute
bei der ganzen Sache betrachten das war ganz
Männle es war zwergler der war kaum ein Meter 60
groß ja dann schwächlichen knochenbauer hat er
gehabt Kaumuskulatur der hat sie die Klamotten
hat er sich an den Leib bieten müssen der hat
keine Schultern gehabt der der einfallen die Brust
hat er gehabt der hat kaum Luft bekommen der ist
wirklich jeden Tag um 5 Uhr hat er sich wecken
lassen aber Karten Minuten vorher und danach
pünktlich um 5 Uhr und 3:45 Uhr pünktlich jeden
Tag der kann ist jeden Tag um 17 Uhr hatte sein
Spaziergang gemacht Königsberger um die Uhr oder
noch gestellt weil es gesehen ich muss fünf sein
er kann der hat definitiv alle Intelligenz
hier nein ist absoluten kleinen Burger der
war finanziell abgesichert er hat Zeit seines
Lebens seine Königsberger hatte nie verlassen
er war höchstwahrscheinlich oder nicht Vögel oder
vielleicht doch mal mit einer Frau aber gesehen
und der der von mir erzählen wo sie leben
lang geht mit der Kritik der reinen von uns
mir wo ich wirklich in Saft und Kraft
stehen mit drei großen dicht behalten
und da sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich doch scheiße
ich drauf es ist der größte Schwachsinn was gibt
heute und wissen Sie wer sich daran drunter holt
irgendwelche Geisteswissenschaftler auf der ganz
hohen Ebene die holen sie nur an runter heute
schöne Sportveranstaltungen ist es als ob das
eine verstehen würde er hat doch keiner gelesen
von den frecher der hat doch keine gelesen wenn
der Kanton z.B schreibt die wissenswürdigen
Dinge häufen sich in unseren zeigen bald wird
unsere Fähigkeit zu schwachen und sie Lebenszeit
zu kurz sein nur die nützlichsten Teil daraus zu
fassen es bieten sich Reichtümer im Überfluss
das welche einzelnen malen welche einzunehmen
wieder wegwerfen müssen es wäre besser gewesen
sich niemals damit zu belästigen es ist absolut
hoch aktuell das hätte ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht besser sagen aber das kann nicht lesen
wenigstens von einem gelesen der der Mut gemacht
hat und das gelesen hat und dann samt geschrieben
das musst Du lesen das musst Du
lesen hör auf Aufklärung und Vernunft
es erzählen Sie mir wo ich nicht
hin was mit testosterona die
anstrengende vorsteherdüse literweise
Samenflüssigkeit und da erzählen Sie
mir was von Aufklärung wenn die
anderen den eggersdorfer Wasser
10 von der Kenntnis Theorie und transzendental
Philosophie weil wenn du einmal gesagt
die Sachen kommen die einfach nicht diese
Arschlöcher also ehrlich und dann ein bisschen
Vorhaut drauf oder was oben schon Nieren wie
lange muss aushalten kann man muss sich noch
Lachen also ganz im Ernst danke schön
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit [Applaus]
ach so abonnieren Sie diesen Kanal
dann wird es lustig ihr Puffer